if you have a website and you're trying
to make money or make more money with it
and this video is for you
what's that believe nation it seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential your ideas
that amazing thing you've got inside
here and I want to see it explode out
into the world for you to have ultimate
success and impact around the globe one
of the things that I get asked a lot is
how do I make money from my website I
want to start a website I want to make
money online what are some of the ways I
can make money from my passion my idea
so today I'm gonna share with you my
seven ways to make money from a website
way number one is access to you and so
this is really powerful when you're
building up a personal brand or you're
building up a trusted entity people are
coming to your website they're looking
for information they're looking for
guidance looking for expert opinions and
advice and the more they come the more
they get to know you like you trust you
and see you as somebody who can really
help them solve some problems and that's
what you want and then you're gonna get
people reaching out to say hey can you
help me with XYZ and it's not the most
sexy place to start because it's not
scalable you're effectively selling your
time but looking at what is a half hour
consultation with you look like or what
is an hour-long consultation look like
with you whether you're coaching whether
you're helping in with a specific
problem and whatever you're talking
about on your website even if you have
really low traffic numbers the people
who are coming to your site are looking
for an answer to a problem right they
have a problem they're looking for an
answer to come into your site you could
potentially fill that void not just with
the information that you have it's a
it's a nice taste - nice tease but then
people will want to hire you people want
to connect with you people will say hey
I don't know how to solve this problem I
don't want to solve it myself how can I
work with you to do it and so if I look
at my website I look at my videos I'm
making a video like this about how to
make money from a website people will
watch it and some people will use it and
leverage it take information applied to
their business other people will come
and watch it
say I don't want to do all that work I
just want somebody to come in and solve
that problem for me or I need more
information I need I need more coaching
they need one-on-one help every can I
hire you to help me do it now I don't do
that as a service I don't work
one-on-one with with coaching clients
but I could if I wanted to write a new
can to with the content that you're
creating on your website the easiest and
fastest way to let's start making some
money it's a sell your service sell your
knowledge sell your expertise to help
the people who are coming to your site
solve a problem and so having something
on your website that says do you want a
consultation with me do you need help or
feedback do you want to have a call with
me having that as a call to action so
that people who want to take the next
step with you can and whether that leads
to a paypal arm or a contact form or
tell me your problem form or whatever
that is put that up there and you can
start making some cash in your site we
number two is affiliate products and
this is where you basically recommend
other products that you use that you
like that you trust that how to impact
in your life in your business and you
take a commission every time that it's
sold this is not a path that that I go
down it's not how I monetize my content
but I could so as an example you know
any time I recommend the book it could
be an Amazon link and I would make a
percentage of any sale that was
meaningful deadly I think I actually do
that for my own books I think I do that
but if I recommend another book I just
say this is a great book go check it out
you could be making money from that
think about the other parts and services
that you use are you sage accounting
software I use Aweber email marketing I
use a whole bunch of different products
and services that if I recommend I could
potentially having an affiliate code
link out there the most important part
at least for me this is you know the
industry can get a little shady a little
slimy because people are recommending
scam products that they've never used
before and so for me anytime I recommend
something I use it I love it
you know I use it in my life or my
business and I found tremendous value
from it I don't recommend anything to
the people on my audience my website on
my youtube channel that I haven't
actually gone through and use myself and
I think it's a really important thing to
keep in mind is you
have a client for life you want them to
buy one thing from you and find so much
value from it that they say wow this
person is really helping me out what's
the next thing
right the next thing you recommend
they're gonna want to buy again and the
next thing they're gonna want to buy
again and so that one customer that you
get you turn into a repeat customer over
and over and over again because you're
making their life easier you're saying
this thing works
trust me go out and buy it and if it
actually works for them they're gonna
buy it right they're gonna come back and
tell their friends they're gonna keep
buying more every time you make a
recommendation and so that's why it's so
so so so important that you get into
affiliate marketing that you actually
love the products that you're using
something that you would feel
comfortable recommending to your mom or
your sister or your wife or your husband
or your kids to use because you've got
that much value from it we number three
is your own products this is great when
again you're building up your website
you have some content you have some
traffic and you're thinking okay I want
to help people more I want to be able to
provide more value to them and I'm going
to create my own product whether it's a
actual physical product like your your
selling coffee cups or your you're
making a book or you have an e product
an info product you're teaching people
how to do things one of the best ways to
start this though I would highly
recommend going first for the the
coaching go back to number one right
sell a service get to know people
one-on-one people who are paying you and
you understand what their problems are
because what happens a lot is on terms
of websites they say okay I'm getting
some traffic now I want to have a
product and the product flops and the
product flops and then you go back and
you think well the landing page sucked I
got to fix my landing page I have a
change of title I got to change the
optimization I got to work on my landing
page you launch it again and it flops
and the problem wasn't necessary with
the landing page and doing the
optimization that part was the product
just sucked like the product wasn't what
people wanted and so what you want to do
to build a really great product you want
to start with the coaching start with
the service meet people understand their
problems and when you start hearing the
same thing over and over and over again
I need help with this I need help with
this I need help with this right if I
was doing coaching and every third call
was about how to write a business plan
what to my next product be how to write
a business plan to the people who can't
afford the coaching or for the people
who just want that answer here is a
great product for you and I think people
jump in the products too soon before
they even have a really good gauge of
their audience but it's definitely a
great way to do it and the reason why
I'm hesitant and recommend units overly
is because it takes so much work to
create a good product to me to write
this book but it's a lot of work if it
flops that sucks like how much work that
I just put into this thing that didn't
work out and I don't want that for you
and it happens so often is that you
spend so much time working on this
amazing product that then nobody wants
because you didn't do enough research
into what your audience actually cares
about you have to combine what you love
doing with what the audience wants just
doing what you love doing is not enough
that's just a hobby
what's your audience craves wants needs
desires is super super important so you
have to have those conversation with
them
to figure that out so you can build the
best product we number four is through
donations this is super common whether
it's through PayPal or if you look at
Wikipedia they often has those initials
at the top whether it's a buy me a beer
find you know buy me a cup of coffee
find whether it's something like patreon
that you're using where people are
donating to you every month or you know
thinking you and you're providing some
extra service for them to make that work
what's really helpful is to show the
amount of work that's involved in doing
the thing that you're doing to show how
much time you're spending on making the
content for your website to show the
plans for what you want to do because
you're you're appealing to somebody's
goodwill if you're selling a service or
similar product or affiliate marketing
you are selling a benefit right like
they're gonna get something out of it
what's the benefit of helping you just
donating money you want them to feel
good about themselves you let them feel
good about the cause that they're
donating to and so that story the
backstory is important why you started
this thing where you want to go the
resources that you're gonna need to get
there they're like heartfelt personal
message like thank you so much for
joining me on my mission it's a great
way to start and you can start making
money with people who are the repeat
they keep coming back even again a small
audience then you have a hundred people
coming to your website but they really
love the content and like they can't
live without it you could get some
donations coming in again put it put a
tip jar on your website put on buy me a
coffee
put a patreon where you're you're giving
more benefit and value but it's so
important that you tell your story
alongside of it otherwise people wing
number five is brand deals so now as you
start building up an audience and as you
start getting known in your industry
you'll get corporations who want to work
with you you know I am known in the
entrepreneur space so I get a lot of
companies who are trying to target
entrepreneurs to come work with me and
they say heaven we want to aply on the
campaign you want to try to promote this
product or this is what we believe can
you help us get exposure most of them I
say no to because if it's just a product
pitch I'm not interested especially if I
don't use their product right I'm not
gonna come on and just pitch you guys
product because you would you would lose
interest right I always want to create
value and everything that I'm doing so
as an example with the Steven Kelly
videos he's a CEO of Sage I use their
software you know we have a three-year
deal working together and every month we
do a google hangout YouTube hangout
where we answer questions and it's it
helps give sage exposure but it's not a
hard push where you need to go buy sage
accounting software it's the best thing
ever if an accounting question comes up
that's great we attack it but most of
the questions are just about trying to
help entrepreneurs and Stephen gets that
he wants to be a resource for
entrepreneurs and so it's a really great
partnership when you're thinking about
brand deals you want to make sure
because it's tempting it's tempting to
take the cash you're gonna pay me in
cash so this is great it's ten so you
want to take that cash just make sure
the lines with your values will fit you
know you think your audience is gonna
like it as well and the key to making
that happen is not necessarily a huge
website with tons and tons of tons of
traffic it's more about the
specialization if you are one of the
go-to places for X or Smurfs or Tim
Hortons coffee or you know lentils
whatever the thing is if you are the
go-to place for a specific niche then
you become really attractive to the
brands that care about that Beach if you
are the place to go to or lentils and
I'm saying that because I have
let me show you I got my breakfast that
my wife made me lentils and things so
you're the V website they go to the
lentils and you rate all the different
lentils and you share your lentil
experience and you're sharing recipes
and you're sharing you know how to get
healthier by eating lentils and died and
tips and all that now let's a pretty
limited audience who who cares that much
about lentils that they would subscribe
and coming back to that website but
there would be some people who would do
that
and then you become really attracted to
the lentil companies right they're gonna
want to work with you like you are the
place to go to for mentals and so you
don't need to build up this giant
website with millions of views it's more
about a targeted audience and you can
really pay attention to number six is
advertising this now becomes a mix of do
you want to go knee should you want to
go broad advertising is what most people
think of when they're making money from
a website the challenging part is at the
beginning you don't have a lot of views
and advertisers are typically looking at
a you know how much volume them are
getting from this and so if you're
giving a thousand you know views a day
it's not really enough to be able to
make really good money off of
advertising you need to think how am I
gonna scale this thing up unless you
focus on brand heels and it just they
care so much about that audience that
they want to run an ad campaign on your
website it's just typically ads are
calculated by how many thousand
impressions that they're gonna they're
gonna get and so it's much more growth
strategy it's for most content you look
at YouTube if you want to have success
on YouTube advertising is an old cave
way to make money at the beginning but
it's one of the hardest because you just
don't have enough views to really make
it count and so it's much more later
growth strategy than early stage if
you're just going to set it out I've
been looking at the other strategies
that have talked about it right and the
number seven way is to build your
platform to be a recognized authority
this goes back to why brands would be
interested in you when I found is as I
built myself up as a go-to resource in
the entrepreneur space I get a whole ton
of opportunities that I never would have
thought of happening for me so one was
the book deal like I got a book deal
with penguin Random House I never
thought
get a book deal I never thought I would
write a book it wasn't part of my
initial plan I get asked to join boards
of directors for different companies
they want me to be on your board of
directors again something that never
really thought that would happen to me I
get asked to do speaking gigs and
speaking deals and I thought going into
this what corporation would hire me to
speak because what am I gonna say my
message is so entrepreneurial I'm gonna
go up on stage and say hey you should
quit your job and go start a business
what company is gonna want me to talk to
their employees
I never thought speaker would be a part
of it and as it turns out there there's
a there's a big market for it
I don't aggressively pursue it because
Nina my wife misses me too much there
she is she misses me too much when when
I go away so I try to keep it to a few
engagements a year but all these things
will start to happen that we're never
probably part of your plan just because
you get known in your industry and so
the more you can figure out the niche
that you want to go after and say I'm
gonna be one of the top three websites
for this one little tiny thing and and
do that and then you can expand look at
Facebook strategy they started off only
being for University and colleges and
then they eventually expand it to be for
everyone start off with a niche figure
out what you can be one two three best
in the world
at and then start attracting attention
to the people who care about other
industry and you don't need to have tons
of views and then so you can expand
beyond you may have some big vision for
what you want to do and I love that like
dream big think big I love it but start
small in small steps every day like okay
phase one is I need to get this thing
done I need to be known in this niche
that's where I'm gonna dominate and then
from there I'm gonna expand my empire
and build it up right so building up a
platform building up your authority your
expertise has been a really surprising
way that I've been able to generate
money on my website and I'd love for you
to experience that as well so thank you
guys so much for watching I made this
video because Keyon Witherspoon asked me
to it is a topic you like to suggest for
a future seven-way video check out the
link in the description below and you go
and cast your vote I'd love to know from
this video what was your favorite way
out of the seven that you're going to
immediately
apply some how to build in your website
and did I miss it
eight nine ten that you want to add to
list even the comments below
really tendency we have to say thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one would is
much love see you soon raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
values is that people passion not one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
it's suppose to mean I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
most of success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details